hey Vsauce Michael here and I am now
living in London
besides popping on over to Disneyland
Paris I've also been looking at dongs
things you can do online now guys for
instance because I'm now in Britain my
team has changed for click click click
calm the site recognizes what country
you're in and then asks you to click as
many times as you can earn turbo clicks
to get two minutes of auto clicking and
when you're done submit to support your
country these were the standings when I
play this website takes a look at your
physical and moral strength and then
calculates approximately how many
five-year-olds you could take in a fight
gorilla Black Dog recommended drink up I
tell it a musician and it will give you
some tunes and a drink recommendation
now we all have sound boards but when it
comes to a button that makes noises 10
100 thousand it's never enough
luckily my instance contains literally
more than 3000 sound clips available
with a click a florist's 105 showed me
my world mapper which is amazing it's
full of maps of the world where regions
are physically bloated or shriveled
based on statistics this one for
instance allows you to visually compare
how many people live in cities on earth
themed diversions image mosaic maker is
nice upload any image you want and it
will spit you back thousands of images
which from afar are your original whoops
are you trying to break the law well
don't do anything until you check out
the ransom note generator this way your
messages will be anonymous and
needlessly frightening if you're like
Pumpkinhead 5150 and you want to waste
time playing free games but also read
some great literature play silent
conversation here you are the I floating
above text and touch every word while
maneuvering around dangerous words
ether is an art game where you travel by
using your tongue
like a grappling hook as you ascend away
from a planet gravity changes and you
swing through space fall to other worlds
and figure out their puzzles once you do
the planet regains its color in Prior
you're a square who has forgotten
everything who you are who your family
is all you can hope to do is read scraps
of paper about you to learn your story
and how to even play the game concerned
Joe is like being the bus from speed if
you don't move your health falls and the
narrator well he's ridiculous concerned
Joe was submitted by spork murderer now
she might murder sporks but the internet
loves them according to what does the
internet think dotnet the site searches
a word or phrase you enter and evaluates
the positivity or negativity of what's
being said about it on the web and look
sporks tend to be discussed with quite a
bit of mirth super pig angel person 0
submitted this a game of dark rooms
where bacon won't help but stumbling
onto spikes means that your blood
fluorescently splatters giving the next
pic an idea of runs ahead you've only
got so many pigs so be careful now if
you'd rather splatter something more
humane be like pyro star and use Jackson
Pollock org every time you click the
color changes not cute enough well per
girl 2 3 4 says cornified drag this
little thing right here to your
bookmarks bar and bam now whenever
you're on a site you can click it to add
unicorns and here's a game that's like
an almost never-ending brick breaker
except the colored pieces you break off
become balls you can keep using now
chocolate milk monsters served us up a
puzzle you want all the balls to be the
same color and when you click one it
turns a quarter turn clockwise and if
it's blue lines meet any of those balls
around it that ball will become the same
color and also turn a quarter turn set
off small chain reactions and play the
end carefully
Lala but in case of emergency call the
emergency yodel dot-com finally
reddit user i am kohji 'te created this
youtube educational mural it's
incredible so many of my friends you can
click their heads to see their channels
or go straight to youtube.com slash edu
to find others like us especially the
ones who don't appear on camera probably
made themselves harder to draw stay
saucy and as always thanks for watching